ام
حياكم الله لم يتمكن رئيس الوزراء
اللبناني المكلف تمام سلام من اعلان تشكيل
الحكومه الجديده الذي كلف بتشكيلها قبل
نحو عشره شهور بسبب خلافات اللحظه الاخيره
بين فريقي الثامن والرابع عشر من اذار
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في محورين وهو
الجديد على الساحه اللبنانيه الذي جعل
مساله تشكيل الحكومه امرا مطروحا بعد تعثر
طويل
وهل تشكيل حكومه تمام سلام كفيل بانهاء
جمله الازمات السياسيه اللبنانيه الداخليه
بابعادها الخارجيه
حاله من التفاؤل سادت الاوساط السياسيه
اللبنانيه مع حديث عن قرب الاعلان عن
تشكيل الحكومه الجديده لكن الامر لم يدم
طويلا اطل الخلاف بوجهه مره اخرى بين
فرقاء السياسه اللبنانيه وتيار المستقبل
رشح الشافي وزيرا للداخليه وهو ما رفضته
كتله الثامن من اذار قد يكون الخلاف
ظاهريا يتعلق ب حقيبه ووزير لكنه فعليا
يعكس حاله مركبه من انعدام الثقه ما يلقي
بظلال سياسيه على البلاد
مستعجل الوصول الى قصر بعبده لتقديم
تشكيله الحكومه اللبنانيه الجديده ارجا
رئيس الحكومه المكلف تمام سلام موعده مع
الرئيس ميشيل سليمان قبل ساعه من لقاء
ينتظره اللبنانيون منذ الشهور التفاؤل
بشان الانتهاء من تشكيل الحكومه وتذليل
جميع العقبات لم يتم سوى ساعات الصباح لم
ينجح سلام في اقناع فريق الثامن من اذار
باسم وزير الداخليه المرشح اشرف ريفي يصر
فريق الرابع عشر من اذار على اللواء اشرف
ريفي المدير العام السابق للامن الداخلي
واحد اسباب استقاله حكومه نجيب ميقاتي عدم
حسن المساله ريف غير المرغوب فيه من قبل
فريق الثامن من اذار يعني الانتظار فتره
اخرى قبل ان ترى الحكومه التي طال
انتظارها النور رئيس مجلس النواب نبيه بري
يستعد للسفر في جوله ستضم عده عواصم وبذلك
تكون الامور قد عادت الى المربع الاول
علما ان خلافات من الدرجات الثانيه على
هذه الحكومه لم يتم تجاوزها نهائيا
التقارب المحتشم بين الفرقاء السياسيين
والذي ظهر عقب سلسله التفجيرات التي هزت
لبنان كمحاوله لاشعار الشارع بنوع من
المسؤوليه لا يبدو انه نضج الى درجه ترجمه
الاقوال بافعال
لبنان بلا حكومه منذ نحو عشره اشهر وامنه
مهددا اكثر فاكثر في ظل محاولات تصدير
الازمه السوريه اليه والانقسام بسبب
المواقف المتعارضه بشان ما يحدث في سوريا
لن يخدم اي طرف في حال استمر او تحول الى
نزاع مسلح البلد في غنى على وجود حكومه
تدير شؤون البلاد مهم اكثر من اي وقت مضى
حتى وان اتفق الجميع على ان الحكومه
الجديده لن تنهي ازمه سياسيه تهدد وحده
واستقرار لبنان اخر الفشل في التوصل الى
اتفاق بشان الحكومه يتزامن مع الذكرى
التاسعه لاغتيال رئيس الوزراء السابق رفيق
الحريري
مقاضاه المتهمين باغتيال عقده اخرى تفرق
اللبنانيين
موضوع حلقتنا هذا نناقشه مع ضيفينا من
بيروت عبد الرحيم مراد رئيس حزب الاتحاد
ووزير الدفاع اللبناني الاسبق وكاظم الخير
عضو كتله تيار المستقبل
البر البرلمانيه اذا ابدا معك اه السيد
عبد الرحيم
السؤال الذي يطرح نفسه الان بعد عشره شهور
من اه مراوحه في مكانها تشكيل الحكومه امر
الان يبرز للسطح
اه ال المشكله
بدايه تكليف الرئيس تمام سلام
عندما عندما اه طبعا اعرف انه السعوديه
رغبت بالترشيح الرئيس تمام سلام لرئيس
الوزاره جاءها وترشح من بيت الوسط كما هو
معروف وبالتالي اصبح اه مع فريق دون فريق
اخر هذا بالبدايه ثم رفع مجموعه شعارات ال
اه منذ الايام الاولى للمشاورات
بانه لا يريد استفزاز استفزازيين ولا يريد
اه اه يعني يشارك الاحزاب وبالتالي حزب
الله مش وارد انه يشارك بال بال بالوزاره
فكانت يعني مجموعه وقت من خلال هذه
التصريحات من خلال هذه المواقف اولا اصبح
هو طرف سلفا الى طرف من الاطراف مع فريق
اربعطاش اذار ثانيا انه لا يريد احزاب
يعني يريد استبعد حزب الله ثالثا لا يريد
استراتيجيين وكل ام ماذا طيب جاء جاء
لموضوع التشكيل
بدء التحقيق نحكي عن اما حكومه التكنوقراط
يعني حياديين او حكومه امر واقع حكومه
حياديين انني بنص بجوهر الدستور بجوهر
الاتفاق الطائف المشرع اراد ان يقول بانه
عندما نقل صلاحيات رئيس الجمهوريه الى
مجلس الوزراء مجتمعا ما عاد في شيء اسمه
حياديين بالتشكيلات البزارين في لبنان
لانه هم السياسي وهما يعني لمجلس الوزراء
مجتمعه هو الذي سيحكم لبنان اه اه صلاحيات
رئيس الوزراء رئيس الجمهوريه محدوده
وتحولت كلها لمجلس الوزراء مجتمعه فاذا
المفروض ان ت تستبعد هذه الفكره ثم جئنا
لحكومه الامر الواقع حكومه الامر الواقع
معروف انها ستقاطع من فريق كبير
يعني لن لن يشارك فيها حزب الله لن يشرك
فيها اه التيار العوني لن يشارك فيها اه
حركه امل ان تشارك فيها الاستاذ وليد
جنبلاط واحد بانه يشارك فيها ما فيه
امكانيه ورغم كل ذلك اصروا ان تكون هناك
حكومه امر واقع اول مره وثاني مره تحت
شعار ثمانيه ثمانيه ثمانيه ولا نريد ان
نعطي الثلث المشارك او الثلث الضامن وليس
الثلث المعطل بتطرح انه لا يريد فريق من
فريق ثمانيه اذار اللي يكون شاهد زور داخل
مجلس الوزراء لانه كما هو معلوم عشرين
يعني في ال في ال اه في اي قرارات رئيسيه
دستوريه مهمه جدا مجلس الوزراء يجب ان
يكون لديها فيه اه
رفضوا رفض بالبدايه الاستاذ وليد الاستاذ
تماما سلام ان يعطي فريق ثمانيه اذار
ثمانيه زائد واحد تم الاتفاق فيما بعد انه
ثمانيه ثمانيه ثمانيه وهناك وزير الى حد
ما يسميه رئيس الجمهوريه يكون صمام امان
اه اه الفريق فريق ثمانيه اذار وتم
الاتفاق على ذلك ثم جاءت جاء وقت التشكيل
ال اه طرح الاسماء فاذا حقيبه وزاره
الداخليه
نقطه من النقاط الرئيسيه والمهمه التي
عرقلت كل هذا ال كل هذا التفاؤل الذي كان
سائدا خلال المرحله السابقه ولكن يعني
ربما اه اه السؤال هو يعني لماذا برز الان
على السطح اصبح الان ال ال الق القضيه
الان اه مهمه بهذه الصوره
يعني هذا هو السؤال ربما الذي يطرح هنا
سيدتي العزيزه حزب الله كما هو معروف
القضيه الرئيسيه والدي ويا اللي هو مستهدف
وفي مجموعه التفجيرات كما نعلم جميعا حصلت
ضد حزب الله في الضاحيه الجنوبيه وباليرمو
في كل مكان القضيه الامنيه اللي يعني في
لبنان ال ال اه الجهاز الامني المكون من
فريقين ال المؤسسه العسكريه والمؤسسه
الامنيه المؤسسه الامنيه لديها ال مع
الامن العام في امن الدوله في الامن الامن
الامن المركزي وفي طبعا الجيش ال اه
مخابرات الجيش وهكذا كل هذه المؤسسات
الامنيه اذا ما كان فيها شيء من التعاطي
الايجابي مع ال مع المقاومه بشكل خطر
المقابله وخاصه ان مهدد المقاومه من خلال
هذه التفجيرات التي تم معها فاذا ما كان
فيه تعاون بين الاجهزه
جهاز المقاومه والاجهزه الامنيه اللبنانيه
يكون هذا الحقيقه مسار خطر ومش حزب الله
بسهوله هذا الموضوع ولن يقبلوا حلفاء حزب
الله ايضا بهذا الموضوع لما بين جاب
اللواء اشرف في في وزاره الداخليه هذا ال
ال اه ال اه ال اه اه يعني يعني ذلك انه
في موقع من اول المقاومه وبالتالي لن
يتعاون مع المقاومه كما هو معروف بالعكس
يعني هو
عبد الرحيم مراد هل توافقه
ابدا انا بس بدي جمله امور ومنها اكيد اول
شيء اللي هي اه اه تكليف الرئيس تمام سلام
صحيح ترشيح اطلع من بيت الوسط ولكن باليوم
التالي اه كلف ومائه واربعه وعشرين نائب
من مائه وثمانيه وعشرين ب بما يعني بانه
اه
ترشيحه من البيت الوسط اللي هو بيت اه اه
الرئيس سعد الحريري وتيار المستقبل اه ما
كان الو علاقه بال اصطفافات يا اللي عم
نشهدها اليوم مش ان الحكومه واكبر دليل هو
تصويت اه اه نواب كتله نواب حزب الله
وثماني اذار اه ل ل ل اه الرئيس تمام سلام
بالاستشارات النيابيه مع رئيس الجمهوريه
ثانيه موضوع واللي بدنا نقولوا انه نحنا
صار فيه اتفاق اه على عده امور ومنها اه
تشكيل حكومه
اتمنى المداوره منها توزيع الحقائب
بالتوازن اه واه الرفض شيء اسمه اه الثلث
المعطل اللي عم بيعطلوا البلد فيه صار له
زمان وهو على اعتبار هو هرطقه دستوريه غير
موجوده لا بالدستور ولا بغيره واه بيعطل
البلد وبشكل البلد بعد ما صار التنازل
بعدما كنا نسمع بالسابق من امين عام حزب
الله انه ما بيقبل تتشكل حكومه الا ما
يكون فيها الثلث المعطل اه ونقطه على
السطر رجع تراجع بعد ما صار فيه ضغوطات
اقليميه و تغيرات اقليميه طبعا اكيد من ها
ال ال ملف المفاوضات الايراني اه يا اللي
حصل مؤخرا اه وضعت عراقيه جديده بعد اتفاق
جنيف 2 على الاكيد اه وضع حزب الله عراقيه
جديده اه النائب ميشيل عون وكتلته
بالواجهه لطلب اه وزاره النفط اه لاسباب
اه اه مشبوهه وهذا نوع من تشريع للفساد في
لبنان نحنا رفضنا هذا الموضوع وتم التواصل
مع اه التيار الوطني الحر اه برغبه من
الرئيس سعد الحريري شخصيا لحتى يفتح على
جميع خصوصا بها الظروف الصعبه اللي عم يمر
فيها لبنان مع العلم بانه المحكمه الدوليه
واليوم الذكرى التاسعه لاستشهاد الرئيس
رفيق الحريري المحكمه الدوليه انطلقت
والرئيس سعد الحريري اطلق هذه المواقف من
لاهاي من المحكمه الدوليه
اه على اعتبار انه المحكمه ماشي والعداله
قريبه ولكن عندما
مثل هذه المواقف دائما ال الكل يبحث عن ما
وراء اه اه هذا الامر اه
البعض يتحدث عن صفقه
اليوم الطبقه واضحه اليوم المشكله مش على
اسم اللواء اشرف ريفي او على ثم اه النائب
الزميل جمال جراح او غيره اليوم المشكله
حقيقه هي اه في هيمنه اه الهيمنه
الايرانيه والنظام السوري على ال على قرار
ثمانيه اذار بلبنان وربط اه ال تشكيل
حكومه بلبنان بالتوافق الاقليمي والدولي
نحنا شفنا تغير بالمواقف حزب الله بعد
جنيف 2 بعدما رفضت ايران من مؤتمر جنيف 2
واليوم عن نشر عرقله جديده البعض لاسباب
غير م غير مفهومه اللواء الشهري في هو
طرحه تيار المستقبل اليوم اذا ت اذا حزب
الله يعتبر لوقت شوي فيه استفزاز نحنا
بنعتبر كمان والوزير علي حسن خليل استاذ
جبران بسيل استفزازي محمد فنيش استفزازي
كل وزراء استفزازيه الموجودين بالفريق
الاخر ما اتفقنا بيوم من الايام مع ثمانيه
اذار على انه هني يحدد وشو حس وطني ونحن
نحدد حصون او الاسماء يعني مبارح بحثنا
واضح لذلك هذا الاسلوب الجديد اللي عم
نشوفوا هو فقط لتعطيل تشكيل حكومه لانه في
رغبه اه من ما وراء الحدود بتعطيل الحكومه
بلبنان وبتعطيل تشكيلها والبقاء على
الحكومه الحاليه يا اللي هي
المراد يجيب على هذه النقطه دائما يعني
هناك التلويح بان الاوامر تاتي من الخارج
واه ما يجري في اه داخل لبنان يتاثر بشكل
كبير بالملف الاقليمي خصوصا لا يجري في
سوريا
يعني فريق ثمانيه اذار قدم تنازلات متعدده
وسهل الامور كثيرا عنده ثمانيه وخمسين
نائب كما هو نعم كما هو معلوم بالمجلس
النيابي وعند الاخرين
طبعا في كتله الاستاذ وليد جنبلاط اه طالب
طالب الاول يعني ومن حقه ان يطالب انه
تكون الحكومه نحنا حاضرين واعطى ان يكون
اصواتنا سهلوا الامور انه اعطوا اصوات
الاستاذ تمام سلام على اساس استاذ تماما
سلام يشكل الحكومه متوازنه يعطي اه ثمانيه
اذار
ثمانيه وخمسين نائب ويعطي فريق اربعطاش
اذار بحاكم حصتنا ثلاثه وستين لا ما بدنا
نعطيهم فقط من ثمانيه ثمانيه مع انه
بيطلعوا اكثر من 12 اه اه و ا حداشر
تقريبا احداشر نائب من اصل اربعه وعشرين
احداش الوزير ورغم ذلك يعني وافقوا على
هذا الموضوع التنازل على الاسرائيلي هذا
فيما يتعلق بال ال ال الحصص الموضوع
الموضوع الاخر انه
وافقنا معكم على ثمانيه ثمانيه ثمانيه
كمان وفقنا معكم ان هذه ال ام اما انه
نحكي
جاء جاؤوا مثل ما عم نقول بخصم رئيسي
اساسي بال بال قصه الامنيه من جاب وزير
التربيه ولا وزير الصحه ولا وزير ولا وزير
بيئه ولكن وزير الداخليه وزير الداخليه
تناقض هذا ال هذا ال الوجود ال اللواء
اشرف
احترمنا الاخيره
وجوده على راس مؤسسه امنيه المؤسسه
الامنيه الرئيسيه اللي تابع لها الى
مجموعه المؤسسات الامنيه بدو يعمل اشكالات
كبيره بالبلد لانه سيد سيكون موقع سلبي
ومعالي يعني اه
اما ارجو ارجو ان لا نقول ارجو ان لا نقول
تدخلات خارجيه يعني المقصود فيها سوريا
والمقصود فيها ايران ان اذا بدنا نحكي
ايضا عن التدخلات الامريكيه كما هو معروف
وربما تصل الى اكثر ولا بد من الامريكيه
او قوات السعوديه
استاذ مين عفوا من عين الاستاذ تمام استاذ
سلام كما هو معروف تدخلات خارجيه
الاسرائيليه طبيعي طبيعي في بلد مثل لبنان
اللي عم تحكيني اولا
انا بس بدي اجاوب لانه يعني فيه كلام في
ذر الرماد في العيون حقيقه نحنا كقوى
اربعطاش اذار ان كتله نيابيه بالمجلس اكثر
بكثير من عدد نواب ثمانيه اذار ووافقنا
على انه ناخذ من وزراء مثل ما هني ياخذوا
ثمان وزراء بيكون وسطيا لرئيس الجمهوريه
والكتله الوسطيه اللي هي بتمثل اقل من هذا
العدد اذا بنحكي احجام بمجلس النواب ولكن
نحنا نعرف اديش ظروف صعبه بلبنان ولذلك
تنازلنا وطلبنا من الاخرين انه يشاركونا ب
هذه التنازلات لحتى ان حل المشاكل العالقه
في لبنان نحنا بدي اسال يعني لما شكلت
حكومه الرئيس ميقاتي يا اللي ب اه اه ب
بفتره من الفترات كانت حكومه من فريق واحد
و من لون واحد وطائفه
باكملها يا اللي الطائفه السنيه بلبنان
اللي بكاملها عن الحكومه هل هيديك الحكومه
كانت ميثاقيه واليوم حكومه عم نحكي عن
امنها ميثاقيه لذلك هذا الكلام التسلطي
وال يعني اه اه الهيمنه على القرار
اللبناني
وبالاضافه
ال يعني ربط لبنان ومصير لبنان
بالوضع الاقليمي ومن منا تدخل حزب الله في
الداخل السوري الى هذه التفجيرات وادت الى
ادت الى دعوه ال اه الاشخاص المتطرفين
والتنظيمات الى لبنان وهايذا لك نعم نادي
في من اول يوم اه تحييد لبنان عن الازمه
السوريه ولكن تدخل حزب الله العسكري في
سوريا
كل طرف يقول انه قدم تنازلات ك كل طرف
يقول ان هناك طرف خارجي يتدخل وفي النهايه
الحكومه لا تتشكل ولكن هل تشكيل الحكومه
كفيل بانهاء الازمات السياسيه اللبنانيه
هذا ما سنناقشه بعد فاصل قصير ارجو ان
تبقى معنا
هذه الحلقه التي نناقش فيها ملابسات ازمه
تشكيل الحكومه اللبنانيه الجديده
استاذ راح المراد اه الكل يتحدث عن اهميه
تشكيل حكومه جديده ولكن هي فعلا كفيله بحل
الازمات التي يعيشها لبنان
العزيز اه الاحداث التي حصلت في لبنان
مؤخرا والتفجيرات التي حصلت مؤخرا دون شك
انه
الخارجيه ان تاتي من الخارج وفي شيء من
الداخل الموضوع يمكن اللي عم بيساعد ها
انه هذا الفراغ الفراغ الامني والفراغ
السياسي وال والارباك اللي عم بيعيشوا
الوضع اللبناني عم بيساعد هذه العمليات
الارهابيه والتفجيرات الارهابيه التي تحصل
تحصل تشكيل الحكومه تشكيل حكومه وخاصه اذا
كانت حكومه متوافق عليها من جميع اردنيه
عليها جميعا وفات ينب نوايا طيبه على هذه
الحكومه بتساعد نسبيا تخلق جوا من جديد
توجد امني جديد او معنويات وبالتالي بتخفف
شوي ان يكون هناك اه يعني مجموعه بيئات
حاضنه حاضنه
للارهابيين او الاستقلال استخداما على
الساحه الاستخدام الى الساحه اللبنانيه اه
نامل انه تشكل حكومه هذا بالدرجه الاولى
وبعتقد انه بعد تشكيل الحكومه ما المطلوب
بذل جهود كبيره من اجل استعاده هيبه
المؤسسه بقيه هيبه المؤسسات مش مثل
المؤسسات الامنيه المؤسسات السياسيه
والمؤسسات الاقتصاديه والمساله القضائيه
وكل المؤسسات الاخرى
كتله المستقبل انه اذا لم تتشكل الحكومه
خلال اليومين المقبلين على اغلب انها لن
تتشكل اننا ندخل في الاستحقاق الرئاسي
بعد في مجال الحريه في مجال الاستحقاق
الرئاسي لا ندخل الاستحقاق الرئاسي وخمسه
وعشرين اذار بات في واحد وعشرين اذار
وفيما باي وقت تشكل من الحد من هذا اليوم
حتى خمسه وعشرين اذار في ايام طويله فينا
بكره فيما بعد بكره في عده
ونامل انه يعني يعني نتمنى ان يعني ي
يتجاوزوا موضوع تسميه هذه التسميه بالنسبه
لوزاره الداخليه
وياتوا بوزير من عنده يعني يستلم وزاره
الداخليه لكن بدون يعني ال الاسماء
المستفزه ومثل ما ذكرنا
تتعلق بالاسره الامنيه لو مش بالقصه
الامنيه بسيطه وزير الصحه وزير بيئه وزير
الشباب الرياضه اي شيء بسيطه ولكن وزير
الاسس الامنيه المفروض تكون غير مستفزه
على
وتستحق يعني هذه المرحله شيء من التجاوز
وفعلا يعني التخلي عن اي استفزاز الامر لا
يحتمل البلاد يعني تعيش مرحله حرجه جدا
قدمنا الكثير من التسهيلات قدمنا الكثير
من التسهيلات واه يعني حقيقه وصلنا الى
مكان اه صرنا عاجزين عن تقديم المزيد لانه
الفريق الاخر عم بيوضح عراقيل بشكل انه ما
بدو الحكومه مش موضوع طلبات محدده او
اثناء استفزازيه اليوم اذا بدو اه اه فريق
ثماني اذار يحدد اسماء الحكومه ال اه
الفريق اللي نحنا ننتمي الى اسماء الوزراء
اللي بدهم يكونوا بالحكومه ونحن نحدد
اسماء الفريق اللي اللي هو اللي هو بينتمي
لاله هذا شيء ثاني نحنا فينا نرفض عدد من
الاسماء هو يرفض عدم الاسماء هذا موضوع
اخر اما انه يرفض اه اللواء اشرف ريفي
وغيره من الاسماء ونحن
الفيتو على اسماء هذا هذا غير مفتوح
في حال تشكلت الحكومه ما هو اه اه الملف
الاول ال التحدي الاول بالنسبه لهذه
الحكومه برايك
طبعا نحنا تشكيل الحكومه بحل المشاكل
العديده ولكن ما بيحل ال ال ال الازمه
الكبيره يا اللي اه اه حزب الله ادخلنا
فيها يا اللي هي دخوله الى سوريا اه
المشاكل العديده يا اللي بيحل ها هي مشاكل
اقتصاديه مشاكل اه الى علاقه بالمؤسسات
الى علاقه بالفراغ يا اللي عم بيشدوا
البلد وهذه الحكومه بتعطي نوع من
الاطمئنان اللبنانيين انه يثبتوا بارضهم
لانه حقيقه اليوم مع تدفق عدد هائل من
اللاجئين السوريين الى لبنان الاوضاع عم
تتفاقم اكثر واكثر واه عدم وجود حكومه اه
عم بياثر اكثر واكثر على الوضع الاقتصادي
السياسي الامني الى ما هنالك اه هذه
الحكومه ممكن ان حل بعض المشاكل ولكن لن
تحل لن تحل المشكله الاساسيه يا اللي هي
استجلاب الحرب السوريه الى الداخل
اللبناني وهذا الاساس واليوم مطلوب وكان
كلام الرئيس سعد الحريري بالذكرى التاسعه
لاستشهاد الرئيس رفيق الحريري واضح
المطلوب من ال اه فريق حزب الله و فريق
ثماني اذار باتخاذ موقف جريء لو كان ب عكس
رغبات من اه اه من وراء الحدود من يملي
عليه اه اه اه بطلبات اه اتخاذ موقف جريء
بالانسحاب من سوريا من اجل لبنان من اجل
مستقبل لبنان نحنا عم نشوف صوره قاتمه جدا
و سوداء
يعني هذه نقطه جوهريه هذا خلاف جوهري بين
الطرفين مهما تحدثنا عن تشكيل حكومه
منعدمه في النهايه حتى لا تشكلت الحكومه
هناك خوف من ان هذا الخلاف سينعكس ومن ثم
لا يضمن اه ان يستمر التوافق
حسن النوايا اذا فيه نواب عدم التوافق
طبعا عدم التوافق اما اذا الشروط وال وال
ال الحلقات التي تاتي من الخارج ومش عارفه
ان الدور الايراني او الدور السوري والى
اخره مثل نفس الكلام بدون الدور
الامريكاني والدور السعودي معروفين يعني
كمان تدخلون مع فريق اربعطاش اذار كما هو
معروف السفير الامريكي املاءات وكلما
الدين
ويلتقي علنا وسرا مع قيادات اربعطاش اذار
وبالتالي معروف انه يوم مش عشان يحكم
اسعار البطاطا طبعا كان عم بيعملوا لا
يحكم سياسيه على ال على هذا الفريق يلتزم
فيه بدون ما نحكي هذا الكلام ثمانيه اذار
او اربعطاش اذار نيتهم مع بعضهم البعض ان
يتعاونوا من اجل حل المشاكل اللي حلقه
المشاكل وايجاد ظروف تعطي للمواطن مش
بسهوله مش بس السحريه بس علينا بدايه ان
يكون لدينا حكومه تعطي الثقه للمواطنين
انه معالجه الوضع الامني بالدرجه الاولى
وهو مطلب رئيسي عند اللبنانيين بشكل عام
عم تحكي شو مطلبان المطلب الحكومه لقمه
العيش بال بال قصه الوسط الثاني استعاده
هيبه المؤسسات بالاسره الثالثه وبالتالي
هذه السياسه التي اتبعت مع سوريا غلط عم
ينحكى عن تدخل حزب الله بسوريا صحيح لكن
في تدخل ابلغ وزير الدفاع بعد شهرين ثلاثه
اشهر او شهرين او شهر بال اوائل الازمه
حكي عن القاعده موجوده بجهود ارسال مش
بارسال مش بارسال جنود ارسال وبعدين تبين
انه هذه هذه القاعده موجوده محميه من
اللبنانيين
وبدات ترسل
يعني الفرصه الخير يعني يعلق على هذه
النقطه اه منا بس كلمه اخيره بدي اوضح
شغله وزير دفاع كان كان لازم يتحمل
مسؤوليته ونشر الجيش على الحدود وهذا كان
مطلبنا نحنا كثير مستقبل وانا عندي سؤال
اللواء اشرف ريفي عم يعتبروا استفزازي
اللواء الشهيد وسام الحسن اه اه كشفوا
شبكات العملاء الاسرائيليه كشفوا مخطط
ميشيل سماح المملوك يا اللي كان يهدف الى
تفجير طائفه بلبنان بين اه اه السنه
والشيعه كشف مخططات خطيره كانت عم تجي على
لبنان اين الاسم الاستفزازي وليش استفزازي
اللواء اشرف ريفي اه اذا فيه يعني يشرحوا
لنا بس ليش هذا الاسم استفزازي نحنا منكون
منهم هذا الاسم كان عنده مناقبيه لقوى
الامن الداخلي هذه الشخصيه كانت الى جانب
اللواء الشهيد وسام الحسن اشتغلت على كشف
اه اه اغتيال الشهيد رفيق الحريري نحنا ما
بدنا ننسى انه قوى اربعطاش اذار تعرضت
الاغتيالات لاكثر من سته عشر شخصيه خليل
تسع اعوام اليوم عم بيحكوا على الموضوع
الامني نحنا اللي لازم نحكي كمان عن
الموضوع الامني نحنا ما استجبنا ال اه
القاعده الى لبنان وزاره الموجوده الحاليه
كان لازم تحمى الحدود ونشر الجيش على
الحدود تعطي قرار سياسي لمنع التنظيمات
الارهابيه
شكرا لك الخير عضو كتله تيار المستقبل
البرلمانيه وشكرا عبد الرحيم مراد الرئيس
ووزير
اللبناني الاسبق للاسف للاسف انتهى وقت
الحلقه شكرا جزيلا لكما وشكرا جزيلا لكم
مشاهدينا الكرام على متابعه هذه الحلقه من
برنامج مع الحدث
ام